bien pues vamos a trabajar con algunos
problemas de porcentajes quiero seguir
trabajando con estos problemas de
porcentajes y en esta ocasión vamos a
hablar de carteras voy a suponer que mi
cartera tenía 95 pesos en el inicio del
año y además que mi cartera va a crecer
a un cierto porcentaje mi cartera crece
a supongamos un 15% si me parece una
buena forma un 15% y entonces ahora lo
que me voy a preguntar es cuánto tengo
en mi cartera actualmente en cuanto
tengo en mi cartera actualmente en este
momento
muy bien y entonces cómo resolver este
problema bueno si te das cuenta es un
problema de porcentajes yo lo que
necesito sacar es el 15% del 95 y
sumarse lo a 95 es decir empiezo con 95
pesos ya estos 95 pesos le voy a sumar
el 15% de 95 pesos como me puede quedar
mi respuesta 95 más el 15% de 95 pero
recuerda que cuando yo está acá el
porcentaje de algo lo veo en su forma
decimal
es decir punto 15.15 es el 15 por ciento
de 95 puntos 15 por 95 ojo este es un
port y lo voy a remarcar más fuerte muy
bien 95 punto 15 por 95 y es que quería
algo importante no es necesario
solamente sacar el punto 15 del 95
porque sino lo quedaría con muy poquito
sino que comunicar te hará creció
entonces además de mil 95 pesos
iniciales a estos les voy a aumentar el
15 por ciento de los 95 pesos y bueno
pues cuánto es esto
esto es lo mismo que 95 más y habrá que
calcular cuántos puntos 15 x 95 así que
déjame ponerlo por aquí a 95 por punto
15 por punto 15 y esto es 1 espérame
aquí no tengo suficiente espacio mejor
lo voy a poner aquí 95 por punto 15
cuántos esto 5 por 5 25 y llevamos 25
por 9 45 2 47 después aquí pongo un 0 1
por 55 y 1 por 99 95 vamos a sumar 5 7 y
5 son 2 si llevamos 19 y 14 son 15 y
después de que recorrer el punto decimal
dos lugares así que llegaremos a 15.25
vamos a ver si no me equivoqué algo me
suena raro 5 x 5 es 25 y llevamos 25 por
9 45 247 aquí vamos bien 1 por 5 a que
como 10 después del 95 5 y 0 es 57 más 5
son dos si llevamos 1
y entonces me queda 19 son 10 más 4 son
14 no son 15 nuevamente aquí son 14
14.25 algo mencionaba que estaba mal
entonces el 15 por ciento del 95 es
14.25 tiene toda la lógica del mundo
porque el 95 es más chico que 100 y el
15% de 100 es 15 entonces no podía ser
más grande que 15 pero por 14.5 es
bastante bueno entonces el 15 por ciento
de 95 es 14.25 ya esto hay que sumarle
95 para obtener cuánto dinero tengo en
total actualmente entonces ya tengo que
el 15 por ciento de 95 es 14.5 ya esto
hay que sumarle 95 vamos bien entonces
tenemos que vivir por aquí
95 más 14.25 esto es lo que quiero
realizar y ya con esto tengo mi
resultado
las 14.25 y bueno esto está fácil esto
es lo mismo que 100 109 109 puntos 25
109 puntos 25 perfecto suponte que este
es un 2 y este es un 5 y ya llega el
resultado si al inicio del año yo tenía
en cartera 95 pesos en mi cartera crece
en un 15% actualmente tengo un 109 punto
25 pesos está perfecto bueno espero que
no te haya cumplido bastante en este
problema porque quiero ver otro problema
a continuación bien veamos un problema
que tenga que ver también con carteras
pero en un sentido distinto
imagínate que ahora yo sé que empecé con
una cierta cantidad de mi cartera y
además que mi cartera creció y se me
ocurre en un 25 por ciento y después del
tiempo que tenía que pasar
resulta que en mi cartera tengo vamos a
suponer 100 pesos si está bien vamos a
poner que tengo 100 pesos mi pregunta es
cuanto tenía inicialmente en un
principio y luego fíjate que es un
problema completamente distinto al
problema que estábamos viendo hace ratón
debido a que no nos estamos preguntando
cuánto voy a obtener al final sino más
bien cuánto tenía en un principio y
bueno para llegar a eso lo único que hay
que hacer es utilizar un poco de álgebra
voy a decir que x es la cantidad de
dinero que tenía en un principio la
cantidad con la que empecé muy bien ya
sé que es esa cantidad con la que empecé
y entonces si yo tengo que mi portafolio
crece en un 25% x más del 25 por ciento
de x pues es la cantidad que tengo al
final es decir 100 pesos esto es justo
lo que veíamos en el vídeo pasado en
nuestra cantidad inicial más el
porcentaje de nuestra cantidad inicial
era igual a nuestra cantidad final es
decir x + punto 25 x recuerda que el 25
por ciento visto en su forma decimales
punto 25 x + punto 25 x es igual a 100 y
esta es una ecuación de la cual podemos
despejar
fíjate bien utilizando álgebra llegamos
a una ecuación de primer grado en la
cual podemos despejar la x de hecho si
factor hizo x me queda 1.25 todo esto
multiplicado por x es igual a 100 una x
más punto 25 x es uno que 1.25 todo esto
por equis o dicho de otra manera 1.25 x
es igual a 100 y perfecto ya tengo una
ecuación de primer grado bien sencilla
de resolver lo único que hay que hacer
aquí es despejar a x y para esto lo que
tengo que hacer es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 1.25 y tal vez en
un principio no te suene muy lógico todo
lo que estamos haciendo sin embargo si
de muy bueno que regresaras el vídeo y
lo vieras con cuidado y te vas a dar
cuenta de que tiene todo el sentido del
mundo lo que estamos haciendo de hecho
este tipo de matemáticas las abolió muy
a menudo son matemáticas que sirven
bastante bastante para encontrar por
ejemplo una cierta tasa de interés o
algún precio sin impuestos algo así en
fin vamos a despejar a xy entonces lo
que hay que hacer es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 1.25
del lado izquierdo me queda x mientras
que el lado derecho me queda 100 entre
1.25 y cuánto es esto ahora el problema
es que ya casi no tengo espacio entonces
mejor de generar la bomba y vamos a
borrar algunas cosas de aquí para que
obtenga el espacio necesario así que
recuerda x es la cantidad con la que
empezamos que es justo atrás lo que voy
entonces voy a borrar todo esto de aquí
y que será bueno también voy a borrar
esto de aquí y esta ecuación de aquí
espero que la tengas apuntada o en mente
realmente no era muy difícil lo único
que estábamos haciendo era tomarnos 1.25
por equis es decir nuestra cantidad
inicial más el porcentaje de la cantidad
inicial muy bien y ahora sí voy a hacer
esta operación 1.25 va a dividir a 100 y
para esto voy a poner un punto decimal
aquí y varios ceros por acá entonces hay
que recorrer el punto decimal dos
lugares hacia la derecha entonces aquí
adentro también voy a recorrer el punto
decimal dos lugares hacia la derecha lo
voy a poner justo aquí y me queda 125
entre 10.000
cuánto es 125 entre 10.000 bueno 125 no
caben 100 entonces voy a agarrar el
siguiente 0 125 entre mil 125 entre 1000
cabe como ocho veces ocho por cinco es
40 pero vamos a hacer las cuentas más
rápidas a ver 125 por 12 250 250 por 4
es mil por lo tanto 8 % 25 es mil que es
justo lo que quería entonces si yo
canceló todos estos evans que me queda
solamente 0 y después bajo el siguiente
0 y 0 cabecero veces en 125 y entonces
puros ceros por aquí y ya tengo la
respuesta 80 80 era mi cantidad inicial
que yo tenía en cartera y sin cartera
crece en un 25% una cierta cantidad de
tiempo entonces después de esa cierta
cantidad de tiempo voy a tener 100 pesos
80 pesos es la cantidad inicial justo lo
que yo estaba buscando fíjate bien si a
80 pesos que le aumentas un cuarto de 80
pesos un cuarto de 80 pesos pues es 80
entre 4 es 20 es decir le aumentas 20
pesos pues vas a llegar
pesos que es justo es lo que nosotros
queríamos 1.25 por 80 nos va a dar 100
pesos y bueno espero que no te confundan
estos problemas sin embargo estaba
pensando en hacer próximamente un vídeo
que tenga que ver también con este tipo
de problemas así que sería bastante
bueno que revisadas otra vez este vídeo
y no te pierdas nuestro siguiente vídeo